not long on on friends Joey obviously at
a loss yeah everything everything but
what was the worst thing you have to eat
on friends do you know what I'm talking
about the other trifle thing yeah yeah
there's a really funny story with that
so well when we're shooting that scene
this is the meat trifle Rachel there's
two pages of the cookbook gets stuck
together there's a meat dish and a
dessert dish and she makes half and half
of each and mixes it together so it's
like a meat trifle with whipped cream
really nice but what we were actually
eating was not that it was story-wise it
was just like whipped cream and some
bananas or something so Ross is saying
he doesn't like it and Rachel hears him
and hurts her feelings but he doesn't
want to hurt her feelings so he he eats
the whole thing he said no no no no it's
delicious and eats it all but there was
too much on his plate so he starts to
eat it all and he can't finish it he
starts laughing so we copped and
actually we're cutting he kind of spits
it back on his plate like that but and
I'm sitting right next to him and I
didn't I'm looking the other way I
didn't see him spitting right so I take
his play to go give it to me and I
scraped some on my plate I go here let's
go again there we go again and now I'm
eating it we finished it take no one
says anything cut to the wrap party and
we're watching the blooper reel and I'm
watching them going on I remember this
is despite
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you